[Musique]
vous pouvez entendre par vous même le
son de la trêve
nous sommes juste derrière la ligne de
front dans le district de goupillantes
le supposé cessez le feu de 36 heures
n'aura jamais eu lieu les forces russes
sont à 2 km
on peut pratiquement les apercevoir et
ils peuvent nous frapper avec n'importe
quel type d'arme 7 portions de route est
très dangereuse elle peut être prise
entre deux feux particulièrement lorsque
la météo Clémence comme maintenant car
la vue est dégagée et les drones sont au
travail
les troupes ukrainiennes ont repris la
zone après l'effondrement des lignes
russes dans une contre-offensive en
septembre
depuis le front n'a presque pas bougé
mais les stigmates des batailles
précédentes sont toujours là offert aux
yeux de tous comme autant de trophées
des chars détruits et des restes de
corps décomposés ceux de leurs ennemis
qui ont battu en retraite dans le
désordre abandonnant leur mort derrière
eux
il est visiblement mort ici
des pertes survenues avant même que
l'Ukraine reçoivent davantage d'armes
occidentales piétinant la réputation de
la deuxième plus grande armée du monde
et affectant les troupes ennemies selon
ce soldat
des informations nous venons des locaux
et des services de renseignement
indiquent que le moral des Russes à
sérieusement chuté
en théorie il serait prêt à se rendre
mais nous devons les y pousser
cela se traduit par de nouvelles
batailles à mener et comme toujours au
milieu des duels d'artillerie il y a ces
habitants qui n'ont pas pu ou qui n'ont
pas voulu partir mais que les frappes
continuent de secouer malgré l'habitude
ça sifflé par là et ça a explosé là-bas
j'étais en train de couper du bois
des sifflements puis des explosions j'ai
entendu cinq croquettes aujourd'hui
le mois de janvier est censé être celui
des célébrations en Ukraine dans la
foulée du Nouvel An et du Noël orthodoxe
mais cette année Olga et ses voisins
sont restés chez eux
comment voulez-vous qu'on célèbre quoi
que ce soit dans ces conditions on n'a
pas la tête à ça on veut juste rester en
vie
tant que le front sera figé c'est
peut-être pour l'instant tout ce que ses
habitants peuvent espérer